our phone number for phone calls is six
one seven eight three zero four seven
five zero we have time for a couple more
calls I'll take the next one
now who's calling and more importantly
what can we do for you today hi I have a
question about daylight in time I'm
sorry I'm having a hard time hearing it
you have a question about what was that
daylight saving time daylight savings
time absolutely one of my favorite
topics for sure go ahead yeah sure I'm
just wondering what is their opinion on
daylight saving time I think it's every
Compton's yeah I have mixed feelings
about it I mean on the one hand I sort
of understand the original decision for
it prior to having abundant electricity
where people were much more their lives
were much more dictated by sunlight I
sort of understand it I don't know that
it's necessary right now and I really
don't like it when the Sun Goes Down
super early in the Northeast during the
winter I know the counter to that is
that it's lighter earlier you know I
don't get up early enough for that to
really affect me like when I get up
between 7:30 and 7:45 if it were darker
in the middle of winter I would deal
with it you know within 20-30 minutes it
would be light out I wouldn't really be
bothered by it and I've read different
analyses some which say that actually if
you measure the cost of productivity
lost by daylight savings time because it
getting darker earlier reduces employee
productivity because of what we call a
sad seasonal affective disorder I
believe sort of like a seasonal
depression that happens from the the
more dark hours and if you sort of add
up the the additional hours of of
nighttime driving home from work and the
additional car crashes that happen sort
of the argument being that if you add up
all of the costs of daylight savings
time that it really doesn't make sense
from an economic perspective so I'm I
would be totally fine eliminating it
completely I mean what do you think
yeah I think you know we just should do
away with daylight saving time I'm just
not sure why the governments aren't
ablution yeah I actually am not sure
either and I don't know if lobbying or
some kind of interests are involved
where they want to keep daylight savings
time I don't really know I don't know
the answer to that one but we will
investigate for sure thank you for the
call a very important issue with the
clock change coming up in just a few
weeks